over at microcosmos dostor you can pick
up your very own microcosmos microscope
it comes with four plan objectives to
ensure the sharpest possible image and
using the included Mount you can capture
images like the ones you're seeing right
now all of which were recorded on our
microscope check it out today at
microcosmos
dostor in the 1820s a man named Dr R
Brandis walked through a meadow on a
quest to try to answer a centuries old
question that had recently begun to
spark discussion among his own
correspondences several of his
acquaintances had come across masses of
a mysterious gelatinous substance on the
ground known as star jelly but no one
knew what it could possibly be but on
the list of possibilities was this a
bacteria called
[Music]
nosto our first discoveries of bacteria
are generally credited to Robert Hook
and Anthony van Leen hook who wielded
their microscopes to explore the
invisible worlds embedded in our
surroundings and reported back with
descriptions of tiny living things their
work goes back to the 17th century
relatively recent as far as human
Endeavors go and yet our knowledge of
nosto is much much older going back at
least 1600 years when they were featured
in Chinese writings describing their use
as food and somehow the bacteria was
named nosto in the 16th century before
we knew that bacteria
existed how how could we know about a
bacteria before we knew about bacteria
how could we see them let alone eat them
or name them or write about them how
could someone like Dr Brandis possibly
look at a lump of jelly on the ground
and think it has anything to do with the
little dots that we need a microscope to
see right
now well it's because nosto don't
actually live as a a single little set
of dots on their own they are part of
something larger than them much much
larger they exist as a colony a mass of
nosto held together like these ones
nosto are cyano bacteria and the
individual cells are usually shaped like
spheres or ovals these cells are
attached to each other forming the short
strands that we see here which are
called tricomes
but not all the cells of the nosto are
the same life in a colony means that
different cells can take on different
tasks instead of having to try and
accomplish everything at once some
specialize in reproduction While others
fix nitrogen to help the cells grow and
some rare cells remain dormant behind
thick walls their main task is survival
ensuring The nosto Colony can grow from
something again should environmental
conditions take a turn for the
[Music]
worse there are several hundred species
of nto that we know of and there is a
wide range of sizes to these colonies
some are only a few millimeters in
diameter While others like nosto pruni
form can get up to 22 cm in diameter for
the Americans out there that's almost a
foot the thing that holds these tricomes
together is so that they can accumulate
ulated at these larger sizes is a
gelatinous matrix made of sugars we've
actually been staring at this jelly
structure the entire time but it's hard
to see because the cells within it are
so still the gelatinous shell just melts
into the background but you can see it
here or rather you can see the jelly
shell being poked and proted at by a
creature on the other side of it that
Matrix does more than hold the colony
together it protects it keeping it safe
from solar radiation and other dangers
in the environment and as you might have
guessed the gelatinous structure is the
magic behind the mystery mucus piles
that people have found lying on the
ground in fact the name nosto is like a
roundabout tribute to the squishy lumps
in the 16th century there was a
scientist and Alchemist named AR olis
philippus theophrastus bombastus Von
hoenheim though he became known by the
much short shorter and a lot less fun
paracelsus paracelsus was particularly
fascinated by folklore and as he
traveled throughout Western Europe he
often talked to peasants and Craftsmen
and other folks who might be able to
tell him about things like witches jelly
another phrase used to describe nosto
paracelsus was the one who gave the
organism the name it is known by today
drawing on the old English and German
words for nostril
the inspiration for choosing a variation
on nostril comes we assume from the very
booger likee appearance of the nosto the
clumpy green masses they form along the
ground one 17th century writer described
nosto as quote excrement blown from the
nostrils of some Rheumatic Planet
falling upon spacious Plaines fields and
sheep
pastures the fascination with nosto came
because their lumpy jelly bodies seemed
to come out of nowhere but were often
associated with rain or shooting stars
it's why their numerous names include
things like spittle of the stars and
star slime we now know why nosto are
capable of such surprising appearances
it's not that they come from nowhere
rather they come from a dry desiccated
state that renders them brittle and dark
against the ground and thus easily
missed they survive these times thanks
in part to the sugars surrounding them
which keep them protected from this dry
State and when it rains their bodies
fill with water expanding The Matrix and
thus the colony into something that we
can see and touch and feel and yes
sometimes even eat so when Dr Brandis
investigated the metto for the masses of
gelatinous lumps he found there nosto
was a distinct possibility one
Apothecary he cited found a nosto
species on the ground that sounded
similar in some ways but his Mass was
different it was a very distinct white
color and it looked more like frog eggs
though not quite frog eggs he did what
anyone obsessed with a frustrating
identification problem would do and dove
into the literature coming out with a
conclusion what he had found was snail
spawn and who are we to dissuade him it
sounds like our nosto were not
responsible for the jelly masses he
found which is you know altogether kind
of anticlimactic but we kind of like
that because over and over again in this
world people find their version of star
jelly and sometimes it's snail spawn
sometimes it's frog spawn that's been
regurgitated by a bird one time it even
turned out to be waste from a battery
treatment plant and every once in a
while it's even nosto because while the
microcosmos isn't the answer to
everything it remains a distinct
possibility thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us the people on
the screen right now they are our
patreon patrons I appreciate them so
much and I'm glad to be making content
again and I've also been happy to see so
many other hosts here on Journey to the
microcosmos it's been a great time and I
am always fascinated by what we discover
here so thank you so much to everybody
who supports us if you want to be one of
these people you can go to patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere
nearby
[Music]